[Break Time!] So now you have finished the hard quiz about factorial.
You might think you deserve a break—and you almost do, but
we have one more thing to learn about "while" loops,
and that's the "break" statement.
"Break" gives us a way to stop the loop even while the test condition
is true.
Here's the typical structure of a loop with a "break," so we have
the "while"—as we did before—and we have the test expression and we
had a colon.
Our general "while" structure is we had a block here.
Now we want to look inside this block a little bit to see the kinds of
things that could be here.
This is just an example of what might be in the block—we have
some code, we have some Python statements, and then we
have an "if" statement.
That's going to have another test expression—we'll call that
the "break test."
That's a text expression that's checking whether it's time to take a break.
When the "break test" is true, what we have is "break" which—by itself—
is all we need.
What "break" means is stop executing the "while" loop—jump out of
the "while" loop and continue with the code after that.
Whatever we had here, this is more code that was in the "while" block.
That will get skipped and we'll jump to this point which is the code
after the while.
So what happens when we execute a loop with a "break," it executes like
a normal loop.
If the test expression is true, we go to the code.
If the "break test" is false, we don't execute the break.
We would continue with the "more" code.
We would go back to the loop test and check the test expression again.
If it's true, we go run this "code."
If the "break" is true, then we execute the "break."
What "break" does is jump out of the loop, so we don't execute
the "more" code, we don't execute the test expression again.
If the "break" happens, what happens is we jump to the code after the "while."
This gives us a way to break out of the middle of the loop.
Here's an example of how we might use that.
Before, we defined the procedure "print_numbers" without using break.
We defined it like this.
This is the code we had before.
We could rewrite that using "break."
Now, instead of having the "while test" stop the loop, we'll make the
"while test" true.
True will never become false—that means, if we didn't have a break, the
loop would keep going forever, but we're going to add a "break."
We're going to have an "if test" that says the stopping condition now is
we're going to stop once "i" is greater than "n."
The way to stop is to use "break."
If "i" is not greater than "n", then we're going to keep going.
We'll do the same thing we did before—we'll print "i" and we'll add one to "i".
This loop has exactly the same meaning as the one we had before.
The previous one's better in every way.
This is more complex.
There's more code.
This illustrates how we can use break.
We wouldn't want to do it this way—this is much worse than
what we had before.
We want to keep our code simple and easy to understand.
We'll see once we get to the code for extracting all the links on the
page that there are cases where it's easier to write the code using
"break" than it is without that.
Now we are going to have a quiz to see that you understand "while" loops,
as well as "break."
This is going to be a pretty tough quiz that you have to think
carefully about how "while" loops are defined and what "break" means.
The question is which of the following are always equivalent to "while,"
any test expression "T", and a block—which is any statement "S."
"T" and "S" could be anything, and your question is to understand
which of these are equivalent to that.
Here are the four choices.
The first one is a "while" loop with a nested "if."
The second one is a "while" loop with the statement and a "break."
The third choice is a "while" loop with a nested "if."
The fourth choice is a "while" loop with a nested "if", an "else," and a "break."
Your goal is to check all the ones that are equivalent to the
"while T", "S"—where "T" and "S" can be any
test expression in any statement.